à
bonjour à tous je suis ses coûts et le
packtec
aujourd'hui nous allons parler du plan
de prévention et de gestion des déchets
non dangereux
qu'est ce que ce plan de prévention et
de gestion des déchets non dangereux
les plans de prévention et de gestion
des déchets non dangereux
ppg dnd est un document qui sert à
prévoir d'ici 6 à 12 ans ce que nous
allons faire de nos déchets ce plan
concerne les déchets ménagers mais aussi
les déchets non dangereux des activités
économiques et agricoles
quelle est la situation actuelle chaque
réunionnais produite aux moyennes 660 kg
par an de déchets ménagers dont 290 kg
d'ordures de la poubelle grise
si l'on ajoute les déchets d activités
économiques et agricoles se sont
qu'environ huit millions de tonnes de
déchets non dangereux produits par an à
la réunion
que fait-on actuellement de ces déchets
64% de ses déchets font l'objet d'une
valorisation agronomique retour au sol
des matières organiques
nous y oblige et compost et 6% dans un
cycle âge leur f et ont fouillé à sainte
suzanne et à la rivière saint-etienne
ces sites arrivent bientôt à saturation
il faut donc trouver d'autres solutions
que l'enfouissement
c'est urgent ou et c'est ici
qu'intervient le plan de prévention et
de gestion des déchets non dangereux
en effet le département de la réunion a
établi avec tous ses partenaires de pci
état région chambres consulaires
associations acteurs privés un scénario
pour la gestion des déchets aux horizons
2020 et 2026 en quoi consiste le plan au
peuple au global qui intègre la
prévention c'est à dire la réduction des
déchets par le compostage les
recycleries le troc le recyclage la
création de deux unités de valorisation
énergétique qui produiront de
l'électricité
deux bassins de vie sud ouest et nord
est
en résumé quelle est l'importance de ce
plan pour la réunion ce plan permettra
de maîtriser la quantité de déchets non
dangereux de développer encore plus le
tri et le recyclage est également de
participer à l'autonomie énergétique de
l'île l'objectif est qu'en 2026 il ne
reste plus que 12 % de déchets à enfouir
comptera plus de 20% actuellement
j'espère que vous avez compris ce qu'est
le plan de prévention et de gestion des
déchets non dangereux
nous sommes tous concernés à bientôt
pour un nouvel épisode